позиція перша на форум Сполучені Штати
нам не підписали жодного
розпорядження хоча ми просили поїхати за
власний рахунок ми мали всі
запрошення Разом з тим декілька
десятків депутатів від слуг народа
поїхали в Вашингтон за рахунок коштів
платників
податків поки будуть існувати подібні
подвійні стандарти
Ми створюємо
авторитаризм депутатів двох сортів і ми
як європейська Солідарність з цим будемо
жорстко боротися друга позиція Я хотів
би наголосити на окремо ролі в цій
провокації служби безпеки
України в тому
числі вчора І
позавчора ви знаєте що я охороняєма
особа були зафіксовані машини
зовнішнього спостереження СБУ які
слідкують за
мною не повідомляти про це наших
партнерів я не можу тому що нічого
спільного з демократією це немає куди б
я не їхав на фронт є воєнна
контррозвідка яка йде ічому вони не
ховаються У нас є їх записи вони
визнають це це
ганьба і третя найбільш важливо я закли
всіх наших міжнародних партнерів в тому
числі тих з якими ми мали погоджені і
представлені
зустріч щоби цей ганебний інцидент ні в
якому разі не
вплинув на підтримку України щодо
рішення саміту по початку переговорів
про вступ і на підтримку України в
конгресі Сполучених Штатів по виділенню
нам фінансування оборонного і
фінансування нам на покриття дефіциту
бюджету
ми державники і ми благаємо що Україна
для нас понад усе а от після 15-го після
голосування розберемося яким чином
захистити демократію в Україні Дякую
колеги тоді індивідуально якщо будуть ще
запитання давайте бо ми вже працюємо
майже цілу годину лише коротко хотілось
би почути які будуть далі наступні кроки
щоб все-таки вирішити цей інцидент
якщо ми
проковтнемо далі репресії тиранія розкол
суспільства атака на єдність Буде лише
поглиблюватись саме тому зараз тут
знаходяться можливо найкращі в Україні
адвокати які розробили плани стратегію
де буде подача в офіс генпрокурора по
порушенню кримінальних справ бачимо
ознаки криміналь злочину оскарження
постанови уряду оскарження дій
прикордонників оскарження указу
президента в частині повноважень
народного депутата там де це не
відповідає Конституції закону Про статус
закону про регламент і інших позицій і
притягнення до відповідальності тих хто
організував цю вакханалію не тільки ті
хто ставив підписи А ті хто дававм
вказівки бо безкарно це не
залишиться ко
ще одне питання А на яких підставах Як
вам пояснювали власне на пункті пропуску
Чому вам не дозволяють
Вис Дуже дякую вам це просто круте
запитання тому що відсутність пояснення
ви можете подивитися на відео
ви не дозволяєте перетнути кордон можете
пояснити чому кажу так у вас недостатньо
документів яких ось паспорт ось
розпорядження все щоб я не був голос
причи це лише і виключно
назви нормативних актів не ситуація яка
є а назва і коли ми говоримо поясніть
будь ласка що ви маєте на увазі
відповідь Я вам не зобов'язаний
поясняти так як ви не допускаєте ви
можете оскаржувати мої дії А я вам не
зобов'язаний це радянський даже не
радянський
советский ржеморда який от матрос
Желізняк який думає що він господар
світу в нього є право милувати чи карати
в нього є право за хабарі
пропускати або зупиняти і поки ми це не
виковерюємо ми не побудуємо демократію
бо верховнство права означає що він має
діяти тільки в межах в рамках закону
порушення закону Тягне за собою
невідворотню відповідальність абсолютна
більшість проковнула і забула для мене
мова не йдеться про те
що Порошенко захищає своє право
подорожувати мені важливіше бути на
фронті і частина нашої команди відверто
зраділа тому що не випустили тому що ми
зможемо ще цього тижня поїхати на фронт
і відвести нашим бійцям що необхідно Ну
вони дуже піклувалися про шосте число я
вам підкажу коли День збройних сил
співпадає з днем миколає